are you a fan of the Wind Waker I'm Tony  and if you are then this GameSpot news  update maybe a bit of a bummer it turns  out the Wind Waker was supposed to get a  sequel at least according to artist  Satoru Takizawa in an interview with  Nintendo everything he stated that the  team had taken steps toward making a  second Wind Waker but the demand for  another game like Ocarina of Time took  over more specifically the sequel would  have had horseback riding but little  cartoon links proportions just wouldn't  fit right in the saddle and thus we got  Twilight Princess instead as for what's  next for Zelda breadth of the wild is  planned for the Wii U and Nintendo  switch in 2017 expect to hear more about  that during Nintendo's presentation on  January 12 to keep up with all the news  from Nintendo and Zelda you're already  in the right place